lauren i love the hair
oh my god thank you
thank you so much honey i love your hair
too we were just saying the last time we
saw you we think was on the football
field right yes for the musical episode
yes hi
hi it's first of all you guys been such
a pleasure to cover this show um you
guys are amazing your cast is amazing
the final season
also equally amazing we do want to break
everything down with you
so first of all what were your thoughts
when you heard that chloe and lucifer
had a daughter that we were going to
bring rory into the mix as someone who's
got three daughters already i can't
believe he was having another one to be
honest
no
i uh
i mean it was it was a bit of a
curveball but at the same time i was
quite excited by that by that prospect
knowing what it meant for us as well as
chloe and lucifer and like we have to
we're so used to teaming up together for
lots of things but not as parents
right it was a welcomed new dynamic put
it that way
lauren what about for you
well i you know at first i hear the
daughters come in daughter from the
future and you know
um yeah that sounds pretty interesting
that sounds interesting but once once i
got talking to tom and joe and hildy i
mean the real
um
storyline of rory which is played so
beautifully by brianna hildebrand shout
out to brianna we love you
such a lovely human being but you know
that her abandonment um
issues with with her father with lucifer
are so deep and
so touching and i think so many people
can relate to that so when i
heard through the writers and tom that
that's what rory's purpose was really to
come in and almost hold up the mirror to
loose fur in a way he's always felt
abandoned by his father right and now
she's feeling that from him so sort of
turning flipping the coin and um
and thinking of watching that storyline
play out between the two of them i was
so excited for it and i watched the two
of them in scenes together it just it
kind of like jumped off the page i think
that's the main grounding of season six
is is watching this very tumultuous i
mean she comes in so angry and so hurt
right and then just
sort of see where that goes
um
i just think it's so relatable i feel
like people
can just
really tap into that and see where that
journey goes and it's beautiful how it
ends
hello detective
the ending was perfect which brings me
to my next question the final words of
the series are i thought you could use a
partner and lauren chloe says that
to lucifer kind of talk about the
significance
of of their ending it wasn't necessarily
the ending we thought we were gonna get
but it's almost the ending that i i
thought made more sense in a lot of ways
i did too uh yeah i mean i love that you
get to see
chloe
has lived a life right and her and
lucifer have sacrificed a lot
and for each other sacrificed a lot so
it's like you
you go
chloe like tom was saying you know okay
so we're together we're in love finally
this is happening but the
the rub lies within the fact that i'm
human he's not no matter what i'm good
i'm gonna pass right
and he's immortal and so we kind of
address that head on and i love that you
get to see chloe
be a mom so to speak and live her life
with rory but then when she
she passes right you
think she's gone to heaven with the mena
deal and then you see her going back
down to be with lucifer for really the
greatest reasons right
if you can even say that help people
he's helping people rectify their their
hell loops and and their shame and their
guilt and so she shows up to help him
and i just thought it was a
a great way to end the show tom for you
having lucifer become this therapist in
hell did feel very full circle when you
think about the pilot and when you think
about his journey and how much dr linda
has really helped him
what did you think of lucifer's
ending
um i
loved it
i did i mean i thought that um it's
interesting katie because i want to ask
you what you thought the end of the show
might be
well i'll go back to that in a minute
it's funny because i knew that lucifer
and chloe should end up together in
eternity but i didn't know how they were
actually going to do that and then in
speaking with joe and ildi you guys this
isn't a very sappy show right so i feel
like the ending was actually perfect and
that we know that they have a happy
ending but it was a little bit
unexpected bittersweet yeah i love using
that word bittersweet
it was um
i loved it because of why why was
desperate to happen was one we address
the fact that lucifer and chloe are not
cut from the same cloth in that he's
mortal and he's immortal and she's awful
so if you have this love story out on
earth how is that going to manifest
itself it just ends at a certain point
so i was like what do we
what do our characters know
for sure and what does chloe have the
luxury of knowing for sure that there is
an afterlife
that there is hope there that there is
all these things and we're in control of
that
but you know she needs to live her life
out on earth i've realized what my
calling is and we have a trust in each
other that we are going to spend the
rest of our lives together at the right
time
and i thought that that was
um
it was a much more
bittersweet and again but it was a much
it was a much more satisfying um ending
for me then they just end up together
kind of like addressing what they need
to address and having learned a few
things along the way and then our very
first last thing is them together and we
lead them together in eternity that's
exactly what everyone wants and i think
that
i think we kind of hopefully achieved
that
i also thought and maybe i interpreted
this wrong but that her version of
heaven was in hell
with lucifer
is kind of
how i don't know if that was right or
not
well i think i don't think there's a
right or wrong i think it's
i think that's the thing i mean i think
what we i think hopefully what we're
trying to do was give the notion because
we know that chloe went to heaven in
season five yeah you know when chloe
dies she's going to go to heaven and we
know that lucifer can't be in him
so there's all these things at play to
kind of like guide you away from the
fact that they you know when when he
leaves and goes to hell they may be
saying goodbye for the final time
i think you're gonna miss my incredible
musical prowess the moment
would either of you guys be open to
revisiting the roles of chloe and
lucifer doing a netflix movie of some
sort the only spin-off that would not
work from the show would be a decker
[Laughter]
i i could see other characters having a
super successful epic spin-off but um
i don't know muff what do you think if
we did a little
i mean i think i i i
for now like this is the end of the show
as we know it i think never say never
there's always something i say
and the notion of maybe doing a little
loose of a movie one day i'm not against
the idea but i think you know the show
as we know it in the show that we fell
in love with that has run its cause for
sure
not be right this isn't this is not
blueberries not
no i know you guys are such good friends
in real life so who was more emotional
uh filming the final
chloe lucifer
screen
i think we both sort of lost it
when we when they yelled cut and it was
the last cut of the show
i think tom and i just went into this
hug and like mutually started
cry hugging
i think we cry hugged for about
five minutes or something
that's the same so it's one of those
things is like you saw you it's a
distant thought oh what was it what's
the end going to be the whole thing like
we finally got there you're obviously
just going through the process of doing
your job and then when they called cut
it was just this like
i don't know it was just like a well of
emotion just just pulled out really and
yeah